[Applause]
happy Tuesday everybody it's great to
see you let's get right to it tonight's
monologue is all about gender is that
right Elvis
[Music]
you know when I suggested hey let's play
Return to Sender but his return to
gender I expect maybe some verses
yeah they literally just sang Return to
gender that's all they did now I'm not
going to say they mailed it in but I'm
going to say they mailed it in
I begin with a curious case a 47 year
old single father Renee Salinas Ramos of
Ecuador
not to be confused with Renee Salinas
Ramos of Paraguay
that guy's a real jerk
to gain the upper hand on his vindictive
ex-wife and their bitter child custody
battle Renee legally changed his gender
to female not smart not just to excuse
his lousy driving
is it really that funny Emily yes good
yes but hell why wouldn't Renee do this
he already has a chick's name ah
you see the Ecuadorian court system
which I've experienced firsthand because
of my bastard child Enrique typically
favors mothers in custody cases Renee
telling the local news quote being a
father in this country Ecuador is
punished and I'm only seen as a provider
what I've been looking for is to give
the love and protection that a mother
can give her children end quote well
excuse me Renee mother over here we call
it birthing person you disgusting
transphobic Pig
but you know Renee didn't go out and get
a wig or heels like kill me does after a
bucket full of zemas
he didn't hit up the Ecuadorian Dress
Barn
also known as El granero Del vasidio
it's where I get my hosiery
no Renee lived his day-to-day Life as a
man because he is one except for the
woman's name
and like clockwork his story has pissed
off LGBT activists who call us actions
outlandish which raises the question
what's inlandish
I don't know maybe a store
so Renee used the law to change his
gender in a noble yet desperate attempt
to gain custody of his children I wish I
had that much Ingenuity to see my
children I just don't have the time to
visit the Nike factory
now
so cute when they work through the night
now on to transgender swimmer Isaac
Hennig and I don't mean that literally
Isaac was born female but is now a male
and competes on the Yale Men's swim team
so at least shrinkage isn't a cause for
concern
Ed
by the way you notice these things never
happen at schools like DeVry I guess you
don't have many sports programs when
every athlete is missing a finger
during a recent meet Isaac came in 79th
out of 83 competitors which would be a
Triumph if he were CNN but for a swimmer
it totally sucks
he wrote In The New York Times quote
instead I'm trying to connect with my
teammates in new ways to cheer loudly to
focus more on the excitement of the
sport
excuse me but isn't that something
called a cheerleader
Isaac I could have saved you a whole lot
of time
wow yet another sexist would say but at
least Isaac who was once a woman now a
man lost to nearly every man now this is
very different from swimmer Leah Thomas
who used to be a man but it's now a
woman and kicks their asses in swimming
and in writing her name in snow
Isaac
Isaac is different this gender change
took her for being in the top to being
in the bottom only four Dudes finished
after him and one of them had only one
arm
shout out to Lefty
so two cases of gender bending no harm
no foul right the Ecuadorian dad wants
to see his kids and perhaps he watched
Mrs Doubtfire too many times with too
many times meeting more than once
and the female to male swimmer who isn't
trying to fool anyone and her losses
reveal that so good for her
but these stories of gender make some
sense this final one doesn't it never
does get a load of this doll face he's a
convicted sex offender with a six sick
perverted history of crimes against
children he also went by Kyle Bailey but
get this now he's Brandy wood yes Brandi
would proving that criminals use porn
star name generators just like the rest
of us
mine happens to be Beefcake power lips
but we'll talk about that later
Brandy is awaiting sentencing in a
Connecticut Men's prison but of course
now identifies as an intersex female and
wants to be transferred to a woman's
facility and I'm not talking about
Victoria's Secret Connecticut Law
includes Provisions that give Prisoners
the right to be jailed in facilities
that match their gender identity which
means a rapist may be among women
because people who make laws are morons
my advice for the inmates at the women's
prison learn to turn that toothbrush
into a shiv like I did as a kid at fat
camp
[Applause]
let's welcome
tonight
get the thoughts in his hand are so
dirty that his own hair ran away
Canadian and co-host of the Jim Norton
and Sam Roberts show on SiriusXM Jim
Norton
she talks so fast I keep thinking I'm
supposed to fit on a cow
outnumbered co-host Emily compagno
foreign
[Applause]
and finally when he sits down his ears
pop my massive sidekick in the NWA World
Heavyweight Champion Tyrus
Jim first of all I would be remiss if I
didn't say Happy New Year to my dear
friend Jim Norton thank you bcpl I'm
really happy to see you
Beefcake power lips
I'm so glad that you're one of the few
people that knew my name I did yes sir I
was surprised when you called yourself
Greg I'm like oh right got it I have an
answer to your question too by the way
what uh I'm promoting a three City Tour
Friday I'm in uh Fort Worth Saturday
Dallas and then Sunday I'll be in
landish
back on a super awful joke I know but I
made it worse and that's my gift
so let me ask you what do you uh what do
you make of the whole prison thing where
it's it's like it seems like when with
every phenomenon there's always a grift
somehow this is what I mean it's like
and like why can't people who are in
administrative jobs like not see that
this is obvious well I understand first
of all uh Tom hanks's roommate and Bosom
Buddies I can kind of understand
why this person I know it's a 1981
reference but if you watch that that's a
good one yeah the late Peter Scott I
know R.I.P yeah uh I get why you'd want
to do this it's a brilliant strategy I
mean you know if I was in prison I just
if they could I'm a lady all right go to
the women's prison it's a smart move
yeah exactly you're less likely to be
beaten up you probably get better meals
and the hygiene and bathing products
there's nothing to laugh at right uh
Emily you've been to jail
but you are a lawyer that's close enough
is that fair it's what the father doing
uh fair to the Mother by changing his
gender but nothing else about himself I
actually like this because there's
nothing fair about the justice system
that weighs so heavily a gender over
everything else and Ecuador is similar
to California in that the presumption to
overcome that weight is so strong it is
so in the the lack of favor for the for
the dad I've seen case after case after
case in Family Court where
um
the Injustice is just really apparent
for good Dads that just want to spend
time with their kids so I like it
because he's calling out the system for
what it is which is basically just a box
that has been checked and then the
entire system it's like a Choose Your
Own Adventure the entire system goes
toward presumption of favor for the
mother for everything for alimony for
time with your child for unaccompanied
visits for a presumption of Truth and
honesty so statements that the mother
makes will all of a sudden have weight
in court the same evidentiary weight as
an actual thing that you have to prove
in other proceedings so that the Stacked
against the males in that system to me
is is actually it's patently unfair so I
like this because it calls out also
similar to the to the prison thing what
our tax dollars pay for the system is
set up right now it's a joke so these
individuals that call it out the fact
that the sex change in prison the Hana
tubs do you remember yes per him right
that was horrifying so I'm glad it's
coming to light because these egregious
cases are should what Lobby the public
to tell our congressmen to change the
Lots because this as it stands is
unacceptable I remember I don't know if
it was the New York Times I can't
remember but uh I Tran the first trans
uh person on death row was executed like
two weeks ago yeah yeah and I can't
remember it was Washington Post in the
New York Times said this is um it's very
rare for a woman to die on death row the
person who committed the crime was a man
that's right but they don't want to talk
about that Iris what's your feeling well
they're not alone they're not alone
great there's a lot of us I think I
speak for everyone in this room that we
don't want to talk about this but since
we're gonna do this
um it's it's funny what they get upset
about it's okay for them to game the
system yeah but when a man does it who's
fighting for his children he hasn't seen
in months and the article went on to
that there was a a lot of abuse on the
other side so he's doing out of
desperation willing to change his gender
on his driver's license and try to get a
fair Shake in court but you know that
once he goes to Court the judge is then
going to attack him for trying to game
the system which ultimately he'll end up
in the same situation he was in so for
men they're going to remind them that
he's a man right who try to do this to
game the system but they won't do it
for men who commit crimes exactly to
game the system so if I go to jail and I
say well actually identify as a woman
[Laughter]
I'm not saying anything I'm not saying
anything and once I get in there yeah
within six to eight months
it's going to be a whole new toward
genpop because there's literally going
to be little
G's running all over the place I mean
you're locked up all day
you know yeah what else are you gonna do
so but it's true but it's like but you
will I wouldn't be gaming this no one
would game the system because I'm a
criminal yeah so here's the good here's
the The Good the silver lining in this
cookie thing is that when this happens
and Crimes start happening to women in
prison
then the virtue signalers might do
something about it but they won't do it
when it happens to women in college
sports they won't do it when it happens
to men fighting for their kids but they
will do it when their virtue signals
start when he goes in there and he
starts hurting people then all of a
sudden they'll be like oh this is not
good for us if we're getting too much
attention for it because somebody
doesn't care more about criminals than
they do regular people you nailed it
that's exactly the point of the whole
monologue thank you Kat I had no idea
that Ecuador is near the equator
I didn't I didn't
did you see okay I agree with Tyrus that
this isn't going to work for Renee and I
haven't been to Ecuador but I have been
to its Wikipedia page
today
and it says same-sex couples can adopt
kids can't yeah so then that that's even
worse for this guy so it's not going to
work he did succeed however in the very
Noble pursuit of getting attention yes
which I can't blame him there we are one
of one show that's covering this on Fox
I'm not shocked by that
yeah I don't know but the thing is for
the prisoner too
um intersex is an actual biological
thing so this person doesn't even know
the system well enough to try to game it
so this person's in addition to being a
criminal kind of stupid well there you
go if this person got in trouble for
talking to people online and as intersex
but I think they said he had an outfit
that he was wearing
um which is way too highly priced if you
ask me but he would wear an outfit in
these like weird little uh chats to act
like he had a penis and a vagina but it
was just it was a weird outfit
interesting did you did he mention where
he got that Ecuador he got it in Ecuador
no yeah I think it was I think you can
find it in landish
[Laughter]
[Applause]
that's
that's comedy right right hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else